do you mind if I ask you about your
health no no yeah I hear you're passing
out all over the place with some big
barbecue you were at yeah well we we
went somewhere afterwards Fred we went
somewhere afterwards yeah what's going
on with you see uh well I'm working you
gotta [ __ ] cut down on the weed I hear
you're bait are you baked all day and
night
no wait a minute let him tell the story
I don't even know what happened no
here's here's what's going on I dunno
what the guys told me this has happened
twice even at work I thought this is
been going on since 2012 I actually have
a titanium plate in my Chen from this
yeah it's um I have these episodes that
come on it's almost like a hypoglycemic
episode and I break out in a cold sweat
and then I get dizzy and I'll pass out
for a second I'll completely drop and
this happened to me once in Gainesville
and I fell forward and hit a curb
what is the condition called we don't
know yet I'm working boys do you working
with a doctor yes um but the way to sing
have you tried not drinking or doing pot
and and all your tinctures and all that
[ __ ] danger yeah he he puts tincture he
first of all Jason said you were like
like you'll have that vape pen in your
mouth the entire day like you don't even
take it out well I mean I do right Jason
it is if it's possible to chain smoke of
a pen that's what Brent is doing do you
wanna my advice my medical advice sure
for the next three months I bet you
can't do this don't smoke any weed and
don't drink I can definitely not drink
and don't smoke any weed and let's see
if you pass out let's see if the
behavior changes wouldn't you want to do
that before you start like doing medical
tests from weight you go in the hospital
for three days for tests yeah
but why not just try that this has
happened plenty of times when that was
when I wasn't smoking surely you're a
weed guy don't you think it would be a
wise move if you wanted to figure out
what was wrong with you to quit smoking
weed for a couple of months and then
like you know if you're passing out in
the street I've had some sessions with
Brent yeah and from the bottom of my
heart I strongly feel that he's just a
lightweight he can't handle oh my god
you think he's a lightweight when it
comes to pot and he's I think he's doing
too much and it's just hitting them too
hard
oh my want you out for like a second
then you know in about 15 minutes I'm
usually okay yeah and then he goes right
back to smoking weed
that's right and then he passes out you
know what my new favorite thing to do is
tell Brandi has to stop smoking for
three months and watch the look on his
face yeah just [ __ ] depression that
says then you killed a family member I
mean I have to deal with the reality of
this world yeah sure do I dare T Howard
if me and him were to have a session tap
out you tap out before I do hundred was
no way harder percent you're 48 you're
not 28 relax shut up idiot
yeah Rowe this is the funniest
conversation ever and this is hilarious
he he smokes till he passes out of
course but how do you explain what it
happens at work when I'm not smoking
well it's happened it's happened
multiple times when I'm not smoking yeah
but I mean I think it's got to be
affecting your health to do that much
weed I mean dude you really are a heavy
consumer of weed and weed products dude
your eyes the other night before this
happened I looked at you your eyes were
like red like like you were there Ralph
right you saw him pass out yeah pretty
much I mean Roth was a real hero people
are telling me after Brent went down
yeah everyone was rushing over he just
goes no no let Jason do it it it won't
look good if we all run over there
Howard you keep saying passing out but
not only did he pass out but then he's
out of it too it's not just like he
passes out for a second he couldn't walk
after yes yes I couldn't you think it's
a cry for attention yes I could shut up
Ralph no I couldn't I did not need to be
carried dude he saw it I know people
think I need to be carried but I don't I
was fine like Jason was there Catelyn
asked me to help get him to the car she
couldn't get him to the uber right so
you weren't even making sentences well
he's going to another bar even Jeff the
drunk says you need to slow down Jeff go
ahead I think you're a stepped-up [ __ ]
off
right this guy's had to be picked up by
firefighters while he's naked because
he's passed away takes one to know one
can you stop Brent can you st. stop
today is the day we raise your right
hand and say I am now off weed for the
next three months alcohol for sure done
all right come on you [ __ ] shut up
shulie look at him you can't do it can
you
you're passing out yeah you're not
saying this to be an answer no no I know
you're not I know I mean I really mean
it I know why not just stop all
substance for three months and see if
you're passing out disappears then you
got your answer if it doesn't start you
know really looking into this thing and
I ask you Brent a question in the past
when you've stuff I didn't even ask it
yeah relax when you stop smoking does
does it affect your mood do you get you
get are you testy do you your patience
short I do get a little irritable look
his mood changes just talking about look
at his face when I say Brent quit
smoking for three months now I'm three
months we got a medical test I'm just
asking a question yes a month like a
dish starting now
what's the date Robin I don't think he
could make it through today we've got
something going on